since the onset of the dong Xiao ping
era 30 years ago
no single issue has signified China's
drive to restore its damaged national
pride more than the quest to reunify the
to lost Chinese territories of Taiwan
and Hong Kong for more than a hundred
and fifty years Hong Kong was a symbol
of imperialist aggression against China
seized by Great Britain at gunpoint
after the opium wars Hong Kong remained
a British colonial Enclave until 1997
when sovereignty finally reverted
peacefully to China in anticipation of
this historic hand over a large
countdown clock was erected in Beijing
Zn on Mon Square ticking off the minutes
until midnight July 1st 1997 on that
night as 12 o'clock approached tens of
thousands of people in the square began
counting down the seconds and when the
clock struck midnight there was wild
jubilation in Tiananmen meanwhile in
Hong Kong when midnight struck a
government fireworks show lit up the
famous waterfront harbour and Chinese
President Jiang Zemin was on hand to
give a patriotic speak welcoming Hong
Kong back to the bosom of the motherland
but outside on the street things were
considerably more restrained after a
hundred and fifty five years of British
sovereignty came to a close no one was
quite sure what to expect with the PLA
come marching into Hong Kong when
pro-democracy activists be arrested in
anticipation of possible incidents
several thousand international
journalists joined crowds of local
citizens and assorted others in a post
midnight vigil in front of the
Legislative Council building in Hong
Kong's central district which was the
centre of Hong Kong's
politics I was among the throng of
humanity that night I had brought a
group of a dozen or more of my UCLA
students to Hong Kong in the spring of
1997 to observe the transition to record
it and to write about it my students and
I waited almost three hours on the night
of the handover for something to happen
but nothing did know jackbooted PLA
troops no political disturbances and no
arrests gradually the crowds dispersed
as people moved on to Hong Kong's myriad
watering holes and all-night parties the
handover itself was thus unexpectedly
calm orderly and uneventful to mark Hong
Kong's retrocession the next day July
1st was declared a national holiday in
Hong Kong the shopping malls opened
early that day and a new one-day record
for retail sales was set thus providing
further proof if such were needed to
support the old adage that when the
going gets tough the tough go shopping
the handover impacted not just Hong Kong
Island which was the original British
Crown Colony dating from the 1842 Treaty
of Nanjing but also two adjacent parcels
of land across the harbor on the
mainland the Kowloon Peninsula and the
New Territories as we saw in an early
lecture Kowloon had been ceded outright
to Britain after the Second Opium War in
1860 well the new territories were
leased to England in 1898 for a period
of 99 years today's Hong Kong includes
all three of these contiguous
territories the 1997 return of Hong Kong
from British sovereignty to a special
administrative region of China took
place after lengthy and often
acrimonious negotiations between Beijing
and London because most of Hong Kong's
territory and population as well as its
major industrial and agricultural
resources lay in the new
territories the approach of the leases
expiration date June 30th 1997 was a
source of growing concern to the British
government as the expiration date drew
nearer the government of Britain's then
Prime Minister Margaret Thatcher sought
to secure a chinese commitment to renew
the lease for another 50 years but by
1982 it was clear that dum Xiao ping was
firmly opposed to such an extension this
put the British government in a quandary
for without the resources and population
of the new territories both agriculture
and industrial the rest of Hong Kong
could not be sustained as a viable
self-sufficient entity it would exist at
Beijing pleasure a permanent hostage to
Chinese political economic and military
whims and pressures under these
circumstances Prime Minister Thatcher
decided to negotiate a package deal for
the return of Hong Kong to China under
the terms of the British proposal all
three territorial parcels would revert
to Chinese sovereignty in 1997 but in
exchange China would allow Hong Kong to
exercise a high degree of local autonomy
after 1997 and would pledge not to
interfere with Hong Kong's existing
economic administrative and legal
institutions for a period of 50 years at
least these twin principles local
autonomy and a 50-year non-intervention
pledge became the cornerstones of the
sino-british joint declaration on Hong
Kong which was signed in 1984 soon
afterwards a sino-british drafting
committee began working on a new mini
constitution for post 1997 Hong Kong
known as the basic law that document was
completed in 1990 its various provisions
spelled out in some detail Hong Kong's
political legal and administrative
arrangements
for the next 50 years under a general
framework known as one country two
systems the basic law granted Hong Kong
substantial autonomy over its domestic
affairs and its international commercial
relations while reserving to Beijing
sovereign authority over diplomatic and
military affairs politically the basic
law defined a Hong Kong government that
featured a strong non elected chief
executive and a weak
partially elected legislature although
the drafters stipulated that universal
suffrage would eventually be introduced
in the elections of both the chief
executive and the legislature no dates
were specified in the document and up to
now this has remained an unfilled
promise on the other hand since the 1997
handover Beijing has scrupulously
adhered to its principal obligations
under the joint declaration and the
basic law China's leaders have made no
attempt unilaterally to change Hong
Kong's economic political legal or
administrative institutions and the
basic legal rights political and civil
liberties of Hong Kong citizens have
been retained more or less intact media
freedom also remains relatively high in
Hong Kong although a certain amount of
pressure has been exerted on radio
television and newspaper editors and
programmers in Hong Kong to refrain from
excessive criticism of the Chinese
government still for the most part media
censorship has been more self-imposed
than externally coerced in general then
the principle of one country two systems
has worked out rather well in the Hong
Kong Special Administrative Region or
SAR despite early fears that the hone
that the handover would spell the death
of Hong Kong in most respects it has
been largely business as usual since
1990
the same cannot be said however for
Taiwan there a sizable majority of
citizens continue to oppose the islands
reunification with mainland China under
almost any circumstances to entice the
Taiwanese people into accepting the idea
of reunification in 1981 the Chinese
government announced a liberal
nine-point blueprint for Taiwan's
peaceful return to China
a year later gong shellping incorporated
this blueprint into his famous proposal
for one country two systems' under the
terms of Dung's proposal Taiwan would be
given even more liberal terms than those
offered to Hong Kong in addition to a
high degree of autonomy and a promise of
non-intervention in local affairs Taiwan
would also be permitted to retain its
own military forces and and could
continue to maintain economic and
cultural ties with foreign countries
moreover China's pledge of
non-intervention would be permanent with
no 50 year time limit on PRC
self-restraint but despite their many
similarities the cases of Taiwan and
Hong Kong were nonetheless very
different most important the new
territories by law internationally
recognised indisputably belonged to
China which meant that Beijing was
legally entitled to reclaim it when the
lease expired
by contrast Taiwan's long separation
from mainland China was a de facto
situation it was based not on a binding
international legal obligation but on
the vicissitudes of a bitter and
protracted civil war which had never
ended at least in formal legal terms
indeed the very bitterness of the civil
war ensured that many if not most
Taiwanese would reject the idea that
their fate should be dictated by the
communist regime
across the water hence dumb shell pings
one country two systems' formulation
never gained much popular traction in
Taiwan at the height of the Cold War
from the mid 1950s to the early 1970s
Taiwan received major US development
assistance partly because of the Cold
War as a result the island experienced a
substantial economic miracle politically
however John kai-shek continued to rule
Taiwan with an iron fist permitting no
opposition to the political monopoly
enjoyed by the gloaming dong when John
died in 1975 at the age of 88 the
presidency passed to his son John
Dingell and thereafter Taiwan gradually
slowly began to open up its political
system in 1987 the Republic of China
began transitioning to democracy by then
the islands demographic composition had
shifted substantially the mainland born
Roman dong elites who had monopolized
political and military power in 1949 and
Beyond were dying off and new
generations of native-born Taiwanese
were rising to middle-class economic
status as they did so they began to
demand access to the instruments of
political participation and ultimately
power by 1988 a new opposition political
party the Democratic Progressive Party
or
DPP began to challenge the Guangdong's
long established political monopoly and
it also began to challenge the
Guangdong's traditional insistence that
the Republic of China was the sole legal
government of all of China one China the
DPP served as a magnet for those who had
been alienated by the rigid dictatorial
policies of the GMD the part
also became a strong advocate for a
separate and distinct Taiwanese ethnic
and political identity by the early
1990s DPP candidates had gained a
substantial number of seats in Taiwan's
legislature the more successful the
party became the more its leaders openly
agitated for Taiwan's independence this
put the Gallman dong in a bit of a bind
they could not continue to win elections
without somehow appealing to substantial
numbers of ethnic Taiwanese voters one
way to do this was to recruit a few
Taiwanese politicians into the Guam and
Dongs leadership ranks in hopes that
they would attract native Taiwan
followers thus it was that a native-born
Taiwanese by the name of Lee dung Wei
was selected as president Jiang Jing was
guandong running mate in the 1984
presidential election when Zhang Jing Wu
died four years later Li dun Hawaii
became Taiwan's first native-born
president this proved to be an important
turning point in Taiwan's politics for
almost as soon as Lee assumed the
presidency he began to reveal a strong
underlying attachment to the cause of
Taiwanese independence Lee Donghae is
increasingly vocal advocacy of the
separatist cause soon precipitated a
rebellion by the Guam and on
conservative mainland faction which
split off in 1996 to form a new pro yi
reunification party now politics in
Taiwan became increasingly polarized
into Pro and anti independence camps but
even as
independent sentiment was growing in the
early 1990s economic forces were
beginning to draw the two sides of the
Taiwan Strait closer together under dung
shoppings open policy indirect cross
straight straight commerce increased
dramatically dramatically in the 1990s
as new opportunities were created for
Taiwanese industrialists and investors
to operate on the Chinese mainland
particularly after Dunn's 1992 southern
tour South China's Fujian province and
it's drew high special economic zone
became focal points for a dramatic
expansion of Taiwanese commercial
activity by the mid-2000s up to 1
million Taiwanese citizens were residing
in the coastal economic zones of
southern China also in this period
informal negotiations were initiated
between Beijing and Taipei with the aim
of establishing direct cross-strait
shipping postal and commercial relations
relations that came to be known as the
three links or santim in the course of
these unofficial negotiations which took
place first in Hong Kong and then in
Singapore representatives of the two
sides sought to hammer out a compromise
agreement that would enable them to
circumvent the roadblock posed by
Beijing's one China principle the
Taiwanese side nominally agreed to
accept Beijing's notion that there was
only one China but with the important
caveat that the term one China was
subject to different interpretations by
the two sides in Thai basil fishel
interpretation one China still referred
to the Republic of China rather than the
People's Republic in the event however
all progress toward increased
cross-strait cooperation and
communication came to a sudden
screeching halt in the summer of 1995
when President Lee done Wei made his
provocative pro-independence
at Cornell University as we saw in
lecture 43 this incident provoked an
angry response from Beijing which then
conducted large-scale military exercises
in the Taiwan Strait the exercises
included the test firing of several
unarmed guided missiles which landed
within a dozen miles of the island the
mounting crisis ended only when
President Clinton sent two aircraft
carriers into the vicinity of the Taiwan
Strait early in 1996 as a warning to
Beijing angered by China's blatant
attempt to intimidate them through
coercive diplomacy Taiwan's voters
vented their anti China feelings by
defiantly electing leading way to a
second four-year term in 1996 Lee
responded by ratcheting up his
pro-independence rhetoric and by 1999 he
was loudly and proudly proclaiming that
Taiwan and China were two separate and
distinct national states having failed
to intimidate taiwan's voters Beijing's
leaders now stepped up their efforts to
deter Taiwan from declaring independence
on the eve of the islands 2000
presidential election Beijing issued a
harshly worded national defense white
paper which threatened military action
against Taiwan unless the Taiwan
authorities entered into early ago she
ations for reunification this was
followed shortly by a veiled warning
from Chinese premier Jurong ji who
stated that there will be no good ending
for those involved in Taiwan
independence once again however the
attempt to intimidate Taiwan's voters
had the opposite effect
this time it served mainly to rally
support for the opposition DPP whose
presidential candidate in 2010 shui-bian
was an avowed supporter of Thai
on independence aided by a deep split
within the Guandong between Pro
unification and pro-independence
factions the DPP won the election of
2000 and for the first time in its 55
year history the Republic of China on
Taiwan had an on Guam and on president
and a militantly pro-independence
president at that relations between
Beijing and Taipei remained deeply
strained throughout Chen shui-bian
two presidential terms during his eight
years in office
Chun pursued a calculated strategy of
gradually pushing the envelope of Taiwan
sovereignty and independence a key
element in this strategy was Chen's
persistent effort to revise the Republic
of China's Constitution and to rename
the Republic of China as the Republic of
Taiwan on several occasions in the early
2000s Chun antagonized China's leaders
with provocative rhetoric and in turn
they denounced him in the harshest of
terms meanwhile in Washington by 2003
president george w bush's foreign policy
advisors had concluded that chen
shui-bian was a loose cannon a
provocateur who if left to his own
devices could wind up dragging the
united states willy-nilly into a
military conflict with China in December
of 2003 Bush put his foot down in a
nationally televised White House photo
opportunity session with visiting
Chinese Premier Wen Jiabao the president
stated that the United States does not
support Taiwan independence nor does it
support any efforts to unilaterally
alter the status quo in the Taiwan
Strait pro-independence groups in Taiwan
including president Chun were
understandably upset by the president's
remarks China's leaders on the
and were very pleased and why wouldn't
they be for Washington had finally
acknowledged the need to actively
restrain Taiwan's headstrong president
notwithstanding this newfound American
determination to restrain Chen shui-bian
Chun narrowly won re-election to a
second four-year term in 2004 it came as
a bit of a surprise to most observers
this time his election was in fact aided
by an unsuccessful assassination attempt
against Chun and his vice president
annette lu occurring just 24 hours
before the election the botched
assassination attempt created a wave of
popular sympathy for the incumbent
president enabling him to pull off an
extremely narrow last-minute victory now
in the interest of full disclosure I was
in Taiwan serving as an invited election
monitor during the 2004 presidential
election and by sheer happenstance I was
in the vicinity of President Chen's
motorcade when the assassination attempt
took place at the time of the shooting I
was interviewing a group of DPP
politicians just about a mile away from
the president's motorcade almost
immediately rumors began to fly that the
President and vice-president had both
been killed these rumors were quickly
put to rest however when television
footage revealed the president and vice
president's wounds to be relatively
minor seeking to maximize public
sympathy Chun held a photo-op session
with the mass media in his hospital room
where he bravely displayed his
superficial abdominal wound while the TV
cameras rolled meanwhile at the
headquarters of the Opposition Guandong
angry people were raising allegations
that the assassination attempt had been
a fake a hoax a last-minute gambit
devised by the Chung camp to avoid
defeat in the election
adding to
credibility of such suspicions Taiwanese
pollsters confirmed that at the time of
the shooting the Gorman Don candidate
Lian John enjoyed a lead over Chen
shui-bian of between three and four
percentage points but that lead
evaporated within a few hours as a wave
of last-minute sympathy for Chun enabled
him to eke out the narrowest of
victories in the final vote count just
1/10 of 1% separated Chun from Lian John
was the assassination attempt to fake a
hoax the evidence is inconclusive but
the GMD camp remained irate sensing that
they had been robbed in Chen shui-bian
second term he came under intense
American pressure to tone down his
pro-independence rhetoric with the Bush
administration now concentrating its
attention on the war in Iraq and the
Global War on Terror mr. Bush was in no
mood to be dragged by China into a
military showdown to be dragged by Chun
into a military showdown with China
meanwhile Chinese leaders sensed an
opportunity to take advantage of Chun's
growing difficulties by holding out an
olive branch two opposition leaders the
old United Front strategy in 2005
Beijing invited the defeated Guam and on
presidential candidate Lee and John to
visit mainland China it was a major
public relations coup for China as well
as for the Guam and on and the party's
approval ratings began to rise sharply
among Taiwan's voters in the wake of the
gmds successful cross-strait peace peace
initiative Chen shui-bian polling
numbers declined sharply not only were
the Taiwanese people growing weary of
his provocative tactics but there were
also serious allegations of corruption
involving members of the president's own
immediate family including his wife and
and by the time the 2008 presidential
campaign came around
Chung's approval ratings had dropped to
an all-time low of less than 20% in the
March 2008 presidential election the DPP
candidate Frank Shea was dragged down by
his association with Chen shui-bian much
as John McCain was dragged down by his
association with George W Bush meanwhile
re-energized Guandong fielded a
formidable new presidential candidate
the young charismatic dynamic former
mayor of Taipei City Myung Joo Myung Joo
campaigned on a promise to work hard to
improve relations with China
specifically he pledged to resume the
long suspension Zhan the establishment
of the three links that is direct postal
commercial and shipping ties across the
strait these talks initiated in 92 had
been abruptly canceled in the wake of
the 1995 missile crisis the election
itself turned out to be something of a
landslide as Taiwanese voters
demonstrated their weariness with Chen
shui-bian China baiting tactics my NGO
defeated Frank xie by a decisive
majority of 58 percent to 41 percent the
magnitude of mahse victory was widely
interpreted as a mandate for repairing
cross-strait relations in a welcome
change of tactics mainland China's
leaders carefully refrained from trying
to influence the outcome of the 2008
election evidently they had finally
learned a lesson from their earlier
heavy-handed efforts to coerce Taiwanese
voters in 1996 2000 and 2004 in each of
those earlier elections Beijing's
bullying tactics had proved
counterproductive causing Taiwan's
voters to rally around the flag of
pro-independence case
in the aftermath of the 2008 election
there were audible sighs of relief on
both sides of the Taiwan Strait not to
mention in Washington where my NGOs
victory was greeted with barely
disguised satisfaction although the Bush
administration had maintained a facade
of strict neutrality in the election
there was little doubt that the
administration strongly preferred mr. ma
and in Beijing
China's leaders could barely contain
their glee within just a few months of
Myung [ __ ] election
the atmosphere of cross-strait relations
began to improve markedly by the late
summer of 2008 negotiations had resumed
on the three links in December the first
ever direct commercial flights between
Taiwan and China were inaugurated by the
spring of 2009 cross-strait relations
were more relaxed than at any time since
the early 1990s more than 3,000 mainland
Chinese visitors were now arriving in
Taiwan each day a tenfold increase over
the previous year
one clear sign of the improving
atmosphere was Beijing's approval of
Taiwan's application to gain official
observer status in the World Health
Assembly it was the first time China had
not stood beached between Taiwan and
membership in an international
organization although China has for now
substituted the carrot of soft power for
the stick of military threat the
ultimate goal of reunification remains
Beijing's top priority and if soft power
fails to produce visible progress
towards some form of political
reintegration hard power will remain an
option though we cannot predict whether
peace or war will ultimately prevail in
the Taiwan Strait one thing does seem
clear the state of play in cross-strait
relations will be strongly affected by
long-term evolutionary forces at work
within China itself major changes are
taking place in China's economy and
society in the next lecture we'll take a
closer look at these domestic changes
and we will see how they are serving to
reshape China's national identity and
self-image
[Music]
[Music]
you